quand on vient là où il faut
s'économiser
pour prendre son temps il a compris on
parle pas de boulot à tarnac bonne
parler boulot note je m'appelle pas
vraiment accompagnent nos clients si
importante
je connais ton discours je présume que
tout ça pour toi c'est l'ennemi
l'un des rares endroits au monde tu peux
très bien les bâtiments aux normes avec
des gens en ont entouré produits aux
normes
des conneries allait pas aux normes
l'individu un peu louche
gêné qui fout la merde frérot pas frères
je préviens si tu viens tu me chéri
c'est moi mr cède pas j'appelle
tranquille n'a pas de pression c'est la
crise vont signer certains ne sont pas
taillés pour y survivre je ne sais plus
vous voir aussi agent pour sa phrase là
encore sur la vague ont pillé la tuque
libres justes et
bizarre même avoir un petit peu nerveux
et les gares
office web
côté des fruits
ça va pas elles sont rien sans s'arrêter
à ça ça va mal agi
[Musique]
il ya quelques temps je n'avais pas bien
du tout et maintenant c'est un beau coup
nous savons de toilette
[Applaudissements]
à nouveau pôle
depuis je ferai quand je chante mieux
les jambes
[Musique]
pas mal
ça va ça va pas du tout ce
m